welcome to the newshour western powers
are rushing to fly out their citizens
and vulnerable afghans from kabul
airport britain says it'll need every
hour up to the august 31st deadline for
foreign troop withdrawal france says its
mission may finish as early as thursday
well on tuesday u.s president joe biden
refused requests by g7 allies for an
extension to that deadline insisting
that forces must pull out to prevent the
risk of attacks the taliban takeover has
prompted the world bank to freeze its
aid payments to afghanistan it says the
armed group's new position will impact
development especially for women
and the world food programme says a
combination of drought conflict and
kovid 19 means millions of afghans could
soon face starvation if the global
leaders don't act quickly well we have
several correspondents covering these
developments our white house
correspondent kimber halcott is standing
by in washington d.c she'll have more on
the pressure that biden is facing dadeem
baba is in our london news broadcast
centre will bring us the latest on the
uk and europe's evacuation efforts but
first let's cross over to charles
stratford who's actually in afghanistan
in the capital kabul and of course
we've been talking about this impending
deadline just days away now charles and
the pressure mounting the tension too i
presume
that's very much the case sahel yes the
closer we get to this deadline
the more panic stricken the thousands of
people waiting outside the airport
become we had a team
uh on the southern gate of the airport a
couple of hours ago and they describe
real a scene of chaos uh taliban doing
their best to keep people back but
firing in the air
using
water hoses
and tear gas
crowds running out of those clouds of
tear gas one lady telling the team
that
she had all the paperwork she was
legitimate in in her plight to get out
according to the kind of requirements
that the u.s and nato
are needing but she said that things
were being made difficult by many people
who were going there
just taking a punt if you like so
desperate to get out even though they
don't have the paperwork but she said um
that she was willing to take a bullet or
risk taking a bullet if it meant she
could get on one of these planes
meanwhile the northern gate to the
airport evidence of
the taliban sticking to what they said
they were going to do yesterday that
press conference by uh trying at least
to keep people away they've set up a
checkpoint about five kilometers back
from the northern gate the northern gate
is an area where we've seen some of
these immense crowds in recent days uh
sporadic violence uh about 20 people
killed since this crisis started with
the taliban at that checkpoint not
allowing anybody to go through without
either a foreign passport a visa or some
sort of official invitation and it's a
similar scenario at the eastern gate as
well another
checkpoint by the taliban set up there
so yes the situation increasingly tense
thousands of people trying still to get
out and seemingly not believing the
taliban's promise that there will be no
reprisals against people who have worked
for nato
or foreign organizations or the foreign
media in the past those thousands of
people outside the airport simply don't
believe that indeed of course the
taliban are apparently are getting a
little bit more frustrated perhaps with
uh their own position they're trying to
run a country now as they see it but
their sort of channels of finance are
being squeezed you need money to run a
country
that's right and this country is in dire
straits and has been for a long time
around 50 percent of the of the
population live under the poverty line
and as you say you've had now
the imf the world bank saying no more
funding for the time being you've got
around nine billion dollars in afghan
money
and assets that the u.s has frozen in
banks
um in the u.s so
some people are even talking of uh you
know a catastrophic situation here in
the coming months
and when you speak to afghans about it
in the context of what's happening down
there at the airport these new lines
coming from western institutions and
western governments now blocking access
to funds they're seeing it as a betrayal
and they're also using language like
this is collective punishment for crimes
we never committed
charles for the update thanks very much
charles trafford there for us in kabul
well the german chancellor angela merkel
says that the new reality in afghanistan
is a bitter one but her government will
have to work with it meanwhile the
british foreign minister dominic rabb
says the evacuations will continue right
up until the last minute of august 31st
let's get more on this from nadine baba
who's in our london news centre and
nadim of course
the uk really foreign is saying it's
going to go straight down to the wire
absolutely and although the uk
government insists they are still
pulling out all the stops to get
everybody evacuated who are on their
lists who are desperately trying to get
through those gates that charles was
talking about and get onto an evacuation
flight the british media now are
reporting defense sources here as saying
that there are still 2 000 interpreters
and other afghans who worked with
british forces who are still waiting to
be evacuated now just a few hours ago um
dominic rob the foreign secretary gave a
radio interview where he
basically admitted some people would be
left behind he did he didn't he said he
didn't know how many that would be that
depended on the window in terms of
timings as to when the
military planes actually stopped
bringing out civilians
so he is saying that they're waiting on
a definitive answer from the military as
to how long they'll need to get troops
and equipment out at the end of all of
this it's a reminder of how rushed and
how chaotic but also how distressing it
is for thousands of people
in kabul and trying to make it to the
airport in kabul we're already hearing
from governments like the polish
government who say they've now ended
their evacuation flights because of
safety fears the french government
hinting that they could stop on thursday
and in germany the media were reporting
that it could be wednesday the final
evacuation flight well angela merkel was
speaking in parliament a while ago she
did not
confirm that at all but she did say that
right now the immediate priority is
continuing to make every effort to get
people out of afghanistan
we will continue the evacuation
operation for as long as possible in
order to also make it possible for
afghans who worked with us for security
freedom the rule of law and development
to leave the country
so angela merkel said that august the
31st next tuesday must not be the end of
efforts to get people who need to get
out of afghanistan
out of the country by whatever means she
has been talking about intensive
discussions going on with the taliban
and other partners about the possibility
of using a civilian-operated airport for
further flights beyond next week she's
also stressed the need for international
cooperation on helping people with
humanitarian needs inside afghanistan
but also helping neighboring countries
such as iran and pakistan to cope with
refugee flows
nadine baba in london thanks very much
let's cross over now to our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott joins me
now from washington dc and kimberley
really the pressure on president biden
from home and abroad in terms of that
final withdrawal date and the clock
ticking away
yeah and the pressure is growing
particularly in the u.s congress where
members of congress are increasingly
arguing for an extension of that august
31st deadline the latest includes one
member of the president's own democratic
party as well as a republican member of
congress who made a secret overnight
trip to afghanistan the members of
congress are seth moulton and peter
meyer both of them are veterans of the
u.s military and while their trip itself
has been controversial
they have been highly critical of the
biden administration said that their
trip was necessary to conduct oversight
on what they say has been nothing short
of a debacle in terms of this evacuation
both men have been highly critical
saying that this is something that would
have been entirely avoidable there is no
way they believe that all of the
vulnerable afghans as well as american
citizens can make it out by the august
31st deadline and they continue to argue
that this should be a deadline that is
extended but i can tell you the white
house standing firm on this deadline of
august 31st saying it is on pace to get
everyone who needs to be out or wants to
be out in time still the biden
administration is saying that there are
contingency plans being drawn up by the
pentagon should the taliban not
cooperate and allow for the safe passage
of people from the kabul airport so the
white house is continuing to stick to
the date of august 31st even as a
growing number of members of congress
including members of the president's own
party are arguing otherwise kimberly
hellcat thanks very much for the update
our white house correspondent there in
washington dc
well we're joined now by julie norman
she's a lecturer in politics and
international relations at the
university college in london where she
has a research interest in preventing
and countering violent extremism joins
me via skype from london miss norman
thanks very much for joining us on al
jazeera uh let's just go back a week or
so perhaps two weeks with so many
prisoners released from afghan prisons
by the taliban in their sort of sweeping
takeover of the country one wonders
whether they may have acted in haste and
now have an isil problem to deal with in
the coming days
well that is certainly a possibility and
in fact isil or islamic state has been
active in afghanistan for over five
years now they are considered a rival of
the taliban the two have essentially
been at war with initial battles in 2015
and again in 2017. so what we can expect
is that islamic state will be trying to
take advantage of what's essentially a
security vacuum right now they'll be
trying to take advantage of the taliban
needing to move on to governance and
trying to consolidate power in different
ways and they'll be looking to fill that
vacuum with personnel on the ground as
well as trying to bring in fighters and
also resources from syria and iraq so
this is something that we'll be watching
very closely it's always a very
difficult thing to gauge
who isil are where they all come from
how they're actually comprised because
you know you just mentioned like many
other analysts that come onto al jazeera
to talk about isil in small pockets
focusing on certain areas it's very
difficult to pin them down what sort of
communication if any do they have within
or amongst each other to know where to
regroup to know where to go to know what
type of target to to focus on
well as you said islamic state is
very decentralized and the group that's
called isis k that operates in pakistan
and afghanistan is essentially an
offshoot of the islamic state that we've
normally talked about in the past in
syria and iraq however with that said
the group is looking to again leverage
their brand so to speak right now they
have always been very savvy with media
with social media with twitter
with putting out kind of messages to
their networks so even though they often
operate autonomously they will use
moments like this to try and galvanize
under that single banner to again
recruit more people to come to the
specific territory at this time
what is interesting at the moment is as
you just mentioned a few moments ago
these two groups isil and the taliban
have been sworn enemies for many many
years fighting what they may have
described as a puppet government one
supported by the west
that's gone now and the taliban are in
charge so who are the natural enemies of
isil
well and this is what we'll be watching
to see how iso responds to this new
reality of having the taliban in charge
rather than what they see as a foreign
or western occupation but again isil has
always tried to differentiate themselves
from the taliban they believe that the
taliban is not
extreme or hardline enough they
criticize the taliban for working with
international governments and with
international institutions so they'll be
trying to democrate themselves as the
true uh the true caliphate who should be
the true leadership and we can expect
them to try and continue differentiating
themselves from this taliban government
and whatever any for whatever form it
takes yeah another destabilized region
in the world is not what the
international community want so where do
iran and pakistan now sit on this they
border each side of afghanistan they
have vested interests on either side of
afghanistan and they have had influence
within afghanistan over you know decades
what do you think is going to be you
might say the outcome or the next move
by tehran or islamabad
well the regional implications of this
will certainly be unfolding in rather
dramatic ways and we'll be watching this
closely
for pakistan again it has had a somewhat
supportive relationship with the taliban
over the years has allowed for movements
back and forth over the border and we
can expect still some of those
sympathies to exist but also still kind
of some watching out for some pragmatic
interests iran we can expect also to be
taking advantage of this moment
especially as the taliban starts getting
squeezed by the west with the world bank
with the un with the u.s squeezing some
of those other financial assets they'll
be looking to actors like iran to
support them and keep those resources
and finances flowing
julie norman from university college
london thanks so much for joining us and
for your insight thank you
now thousands of afghan refugees abroad
say that they're facing even more
uncertainty after the taliban take over
bhavni mittal met some of them in
india's capital new delhi
we're here outside the united nations
high commission for refugees or unhcr in
new delhi where more than a thousand
afghan nationals who've been living in
new delhi have been on hunger strike
they've been here protesting for three
days day and night they're demanding the
refugee agency fast track their asylum
claims resettle them and also guarantee
them security i got afghanistan people
in afghanistan may die one day because
of the war but we refugees in india feel
like we die every day it's like being
imprisoned
we'll stay here until they fulfill our
demands even if it takes months just
like the indian farmers have been
protesting we too will keep sitting here
our protest has been growing
since india is not a signatory to the
united nations refugee convention nor
its protocol asylum seekers in the
country depend on the unhcr for a
refugee card now this card allows them
to live in india but because it's not
recognized by the authorities or
multiple agencies in the country it
gives refugees limited opportunities
to work to study or even find a home
hundreds of afghans are trying to enter
pakistan at the tokum border crossing
but with no proper documents many are
stuck on another side osama bin javed
has this report from the pakistan
afghanistan border
from turkum afghanistan i've just
entered torkham on the pakistani side
this is the main border crossing between
the two countries for trade and for
people as you can see taliban fighters
are manning all the border posts across
the country with neighboring countries
including central asian states pakistan
and iran and these fighters have been
telling us that they are allowing
everyone to cross the border now the
problem here as you can see hundreds of
people have been gathering every day uh
since kabul uh came to the control of
the taliban on august the 15th and these
people have been trying to get inside
pakistan the pakistani authorities say
that they will only allow people who
have the right documentation to make
sure that no extremist elements no
terrorist groups or no infiltration of
pakistan can take place
my family and kids are across in
pakistan and we have been waiting at
this border crossing for one week and
we'll be here until we're allowed to go
as the trucks go back and forth
trying to earn a living in this area for
humanitarian reasons the soldiers have
not been stopping them but they've been
carrying cigarettes and other things
that they've been trying to smuggle
across the border and make a quick buck
people have been saying they're
desperate not just to cross into
pakistan for safety but because they
have tribal ties on either side of the
line which divides the two countries and
they want to visit their families they
want to go and meet people who are
either sick and who've passed away but
so far if they don't have the right
documentation then